it was a rare chance to see their King
on Friday Thailand's King mahavajira
Longhorn was due to make a public
appearance on his way to the Grand
Palace for a ceremony to celebrate his
71st birthday
he only made a split-second appearance
but it was all these royalists needed
I am happy just to be able to see his
car or catch a glance of him I've come
to see the royal family many times and
nothing can compare to the feeling
Majesty opened the newly elected
Parliament earlier in the month
marking the beginning of what has been a
long process in selecting a prime
minister
the country's political future hangs in
the balance largely because of last
Majesty or crime against The Sovereign
in article 112 of the criminal code ties
are taught from a young age to respect
the monarchy to do otherwise risks along
prison sentence under the last Majesty
law anyone showing royalty in a bad
light could land themselves in jail for
up to 15 years for each offense
the winner of the election in May the
move forward party has proposed reducing
jail time for Royal defamation and
barring anyone other than the palace
from taking legal action a reform agenda
that's prevented its Leader Peter
limteron rat from becoming prime
minister
the party which came second in the
election putai is set to nominate its
candidate but conservatives say they
want Peter's party barred from the
Coalition before they pledge support
there needs to be a protection for a
member of the Royal Institution because
as I have said before this is the very
pillar this is the very ingredient that
hold Thai people together in unity
but move forward and peace say they're
not going back on their promise
ironically if they are successful in
Bucky move forward party from government
it actually does not reduce the chances
of 112 being submitted to Parliament
anyway because that's done by the
Legislative route in recent years tens
of thousands of protesters have held
huge rallies to question the power of
the monarchy
something that would have been Taboo in
the past
the move forward party's surprise
election Victory shows a clamor for
change but opposition and peace say the
party's failure to form a government
demonstrates how the system in Thailand
Works Barney below Al Jazeera Bangkok